[Music]
Randy Gonzalez father from The Tick Tock
Duo Inky boys has died he was 35 years
old
The Source close to the family tells TMZ
that Randy died following his battle
with colon cancer
a fight he was open about with his fans
on social media
first keep what we got the headphones
it's gonna be five hours man five hours
chemo
pray that everything goes okay
I'm feeling I'm feeling all right I'm
feeling good feeling like Unstoppable
what I can use
nervous
I just want to get it over with
Randy and his son Bryce are known for
creating funny viral videos together for
nothing you'll give me some gas money
you got five dollars on me yeah the pair
blew up after starting their Tick Tock
journey in 2019. where did the icky boys
go Bryce tell them where we went
[Music]
we ain't going nowhere
and Bryce's popularity even got him a
role on NBC's Lopez vs Lopez my dad
loves Target yeah well good thing it's
not your real debt yes is mommy says you
just say that to mask your own
insecurities since your dad left you
damn
I cut Like a Knife up top
the fact that my grandkid on the show
has 17 million Tick-Tock followers is
disheartening to me as a performer but
we'll catch up no I mean I mean I'm a
grandfather in this show too so yeah
um
you know until mine conceives we're
gonna just do this meanwhile behind the
scenes Randy was battling colon cancer
he revealed his diagnosis last April he
told fans he was given two to three
years to live but that chemotherapy
could extend things a possible five more
years it's been so amazing that God
keeps on blessing me and my family Bryce
got an NBC with George Lopez we got so
much going on and it's just such a
blessing that everything is
is going good even though it is this is
the worst time of my life I did not
gonna let it you know get to me Randy
survived by his wife and three children
[Music]